boa tarde eu sou pedro vida e eu estou
extremamente feliz de fazer parte de um
tecto
tese dentro de uma escola isso porque a
escola de fato é um ambiente que me
deixa mais à vontade em um ambiente que
eu decidi que eu ia passar o resto da
minha vida freqüentando muito se fala
sobre uma educação básica desatualizada
se fala sobre educação que não está
acompanhando as necessidades das novas
gerações
então eu queria logo de cara perguntar
pra vocês que vocês acham
vocês acreditam que as escolas elas
estão se atualizando
eu trouxe aqui três itens para a gente
avaliar
são itens muito presente nas escolas
atuais cada vez mais presentes as
escolas atuais que o ensino bilíngue o
ensino integral ea robótica
eu não sei a idade de vocês mas eu tenho
33 anos e eu não lembro não me recordo
de muitas escolas que ofereciam esses
três itens ou pelo menos um desses itens
na época que eu era estudante a da
educação básica
isso quer dizer então que as escolas de
fato elas estão se atualizando
elas estão trazendo novidade mas porque
é que a gente continua com a impressão
de que as escolas continuam os
atualizados porque a gente não tem a
sensação de que está tudo certo com a
educação básica
eu queria pedir para vocês pensarem
comigo sobre a teoria que eu pensei
sozinho e queria compartilhar com vocês
eu queria que a gente pensasse um
pouquinho sobre o processo de
atualização das escolas
omar que está acontecendo de verdade
então eu comecei a perceber que o mundo
muda a sociedade se transforma ea escola
tá ali desesperadamente correndo atrás
da atualização dela
então se a gente tem uma globalização se
a gente tem uma sociedade cada vez mais
conectada hoje pode colocar o ensino
bilíngue trás ele só uma linha de inglês
espanhol ou outro idioma não é
necessário então agora a gente tem uma
oportunidade de ensino bilíngue
você tem uma reestruturação social uma
reestruturação na família
a gente tem o ensino integral então
agora os pais podem contar com a escola
para deixar seus filhos no contraturno
enfim dentro com uma programação
educacional
vez mais a necessidade da atualização
tecnológica robótica programação
a gente traz para dentro da escola só
que o problema disso é que vai surgir
uma nova demanda uma nova necessidade ea
escola vai está lá desesperadamente
correndo atrás por uma atualização na
indústria da moda a gente tem dois tipos
de marca um são as marcas que lançam as
tendências e dois são aquelas marcas que
aguardam as tendências para se atualizar
e aí eu digo pra vocês que as escolas
elas não podem de forma alguma se aquela
marca que fica esperando a tendência
para se atualizar as escolas precisam
ser as lançar dores das tendências
a escola hoje e sempre
é o maior celeiro criativo do mundo é
nela que estão as crianças e jovens
super capazes de pensar de forma mais
livre sem amarras sociais de pensar no
novo e pensar sim novidade mas as
chances de própria ti passam eles são
muito melhor em alguns momentos são
melhor realizados por crianças e jovens
hoje no intervalo a gente teve esse
prototipação e vocês podem pensar em que
participou
há quanto tempo vocês levaram planejando
demais aquilo que vocês vão fazer né as
crianças e jovens eles têm menos e menos
medo do erro
eles fazem mais rápido eles testam ele
tentam se tiver errado eles aprendem com
erro
eu queria destacar uma frase que eu
gosto muito que é ser contra o erro vai
contar um novo é muito comum que dentro
das escolas
a gente seja contra o erro né eu
acredito que o erro faz parte do
processo de aprendizado onde na verdade
falam sobre isso mas na prática a escola
continua fazendo com que o erro ele não
seja parte do processo
eu vou sair do script um pouquinho pra
falar uma coisa que aconteceu comigo
ontem eu vim aqui pra poder fazer hoje o
ensaio final ver a questão do sol
questão da iluminação é e eu sair daqui
um pouco nervoso quem me conhece sabe
que eu sou mais tranqüilo para falar em
público mas eu saí um pouco mais nervoso
não sei se foram três letras vermelhas
que estava atrás de mim
a iluminação mas de fato eu saí um pouco
mais nervoso e
pensando no carro porque é que eu tinha
ficado tão nervoso e fiquei pensando
cheguei em casa fui tentar repassar o
que ele fala pra você estava nervoso
nervoso nervoso o que pensam mas por que
está acontecendo comigo hoje antes de
dormir já na hora de dormir eu comecei a
pensar o seguinte eu acho que esse foi
um teste e acho que isso foi uma
mensagem para que o relembrar esse o
sentimento que eu tinha quando não
estudava muito prova do dia final diante
do dia posterior
é aquela sensação de que você vai dormir
disputas não conseguir não estudei tudo
então dá aquele nervoso você acorda
nervoso vai pra escola nervoso e o que
você fica pensando que você vai
conseguir fazer ou não daquele daquele
daquela prova e disse acho que foi um
teste eu acho que esse foi um em teste
para perceber que a gente precisa é
pensar que a criança é a ela de fato
precisa errar pra poder aprender então
você imagina se a gente pressionasse a
força criativa das crianças e dos jovens
para o impacto social
vocês imaginam se a gente exercitar se
com elas dia após dia ano após ano o
exercício da inovação social
imagina todas elas pensando em conseguir
achar soluções para problemáticas
sociais
vou contar um pouco da minha história
para você entender o porquê eu falei de
tudo isso logo no começo eu sou
jornalista de formação e alguns anos eu
trabalhava com comunicação empresarial
eu trabalhava com responsabilidade
socioambiental corporativa eu criava
projetos e responsabilidade
socioambiental corporativa fossem para
empresas pequenas médias ou grandes
até que uma escola particular do recife
e convidou como empresa contratante para
que eu pensasse um projeto e
responsabilidade social envolvendo os
alunos
eu tô aqui pra vocês nessa primeira
experiência que eu tive dentro da
educação básica
a escola
queria trabalhar um a temática
específica que é a gestão de resíduos e
já tinham público quer o quinto ano
os meninos de 10 e 11 anos pra gente
trabalhar então a gente foi como todo
mundo faz e planejou todo o projeto a
gente chegou dentro de sala de aula para
que a gente pudesse amarrar as coisas e
capacitar aqueles meninos para que eles
fossem multiplicadores daquilo que a
gente tava querendo ensinar mas no
momento eu coloquei o pé dentro da sala
de aula que eu comecei a conversar com
os meninos que olhei nos olhos dos
meninos eu comecei a perceber que a
coisa é um pouco diferente
eu comecei a perceber a força criativa
que aquelas crianças tinham eles
começaram a criar junto comigo os
processos do projeto
então não ia fazer uma coisa será que
ela ia chegar lá na la com tudo pronto
eles iam apenas balançar a cabeça e
comecei a perceber que o projeto é
crescer muito mais se aproveitasse essa
força das crianças
a gente começou a desenvolver o projeto
a gente mapeou prédios do entorno da
escola e esses meninos atuarão dentro
desses condomínios
eles iam marcar reuniões de condomínio
com o síndico a com os moradores
passavam de porta em porta e todo o
contexto ele sempre muito até com
questões problemáticas que foram
encontradas no meio do caminho eles
muito engajados e muito certos de que
iriam chegar no resultado final ea gente
conseguiu a gente conseguiu implantar a
gestão de resíduos em 20 prédios
estou falando de prédios com 50 60
apartamentos em prédios grandes ea gente
conseguiu implantar a coleta seletiva
dentro desses prédios e outra pra vocês
uma outra experiência que eu queria
compartilhar que foi já em outra escola
quando uma aluna de dez anos ele me
chamou e disse tio pedro é o que iria
criar um projeto social eu sei que tu és
a pessoa está fazendo isso aqui dentro
de tudo bem vamos nessa
como fazer qual o projeto social que
querem desenvolver e aí ele disse pra
mim que queria trabalhar um projeto
social para ajudar os refugiados da
síria nesse momento minha cabeça de um
noel disputa iria dormir sem é assim
agora que eu vou falar para essa criança
como é que eu vou fazê la de fato chegar
no objetivo que ela quer é mesmo tempo
pensei assim eu fiz olha uma das coisas
que eu não posso fazer é tolerado
a vontade dessa criança não sou eu que
vou chegar pra ele pra dizer que a
dificuldade é maior nem o menor há a
vontade dele era válida
então parecem ter com ele puxei
conversei sobre o que eu sabia sobre a
realidade da síria e disse olha vamos
fazer o seguinte vem pra cá se junta um
grupo de ação social da escola que a
gente está desenvolvendo vão criar ações
sociais junto os projetos e aí a gente
cria junto que a gente vai fazer em
relação aos refugiados da síria é esse
menino veio ele se envolveu ele
participou de vários outros pra outros
projetos e no final no final e que
existe um pouco da questão dos
refugiados da síria
acho que temporariamente provavelmente
isso vai reacender nenê no futuro mas
naquele momento ele existiu só quando a
resistência orgânica não foi ninguém
chegou pra ele pra dizer bicho não vai
prejudicar minha mais difícil vamos
chegar aqui vamos compensar no entorno
não foi uma coisa que partiu dele é
confiar para trazer uma outra
experiência a que foi de alunos que é um
projeto inclusive que está em atuação
agora de alunos estão criando um sistema
de coleta seletiva só que dessa vez em
parceria com a catadora de recicláveis
a gente pensou em como iria construir
esse projeto juntos ea gente chegou à
conclusão que a gente não poderia
depender do caminhão da confronta que
passa
isso por conta de tempo né de lidar com
a falta só passa uma vez por semana e já
começou a pensar porque a gente poderia
fazer fora do sistema tradicional
e pra que a gente conseguisse chegar no
resultado final da coleta seletiva e aí
a gente chegou na questão da figura do
catador da catadora
e aí foi quando a gente descobriu uma
catadora e trabalha no bairro da escola
e trouxe ela para dentro da escola para
que esses meninos pudessem trocar idéias
com elas para que as meninas pudessem
conversar e entender a realidade daquela
catadora
eles começaram a descobrir quanto custa
um quilo do alumínio quanto custa o
quilo do plástico
quanto é que ela consegue levantar gerar
renda para sustentar a família dela e eu
tenho um problema que é muito específica
né ela trabalhava não com a carroça mas
com uma kombi ea kombi estava muito
honrada e aí começou a dizer olha a
gente precisa começar dando segurança
qualidade e qualidade e segurança do
trabalho pra ela
vamos ver o que ele pode fazer em
relação à cuba e ao ferramenta de
trabalho daquela catadora
e aí quando a gente fez uma mobilização
social na envolvendo países envolvendo
em torno professores
desde que conseguiu fazer a reforma essa
kombi né teve um dia inclusive dentro da
escola que a gente conseguiu fazer um
evento pra que isso acontecesse e
simbolicamente entregou a gente tem um
grafiteiro ele fez a arte na kombi não
foi um momento foi um evento na verdade
que a gente fez e muito gratificante as
crianças estavam muito felizes de ter
conseguido chegar ali eles conseguiram
mobilizar empresas que trabalham na área
de automóveis que ajudaram na reforma na
parte mecânica da reforma da captação da
kombi é conseguiram cobrir recursos
financeiros para ajudar também
eles foram muito muito forte e eu lembro
muito bom quando a gente estava na
escola no dia da entrega da simbólica da
colômbia falar muito pra eles e dizer
por que bom que vocês estão felizes que
bom que a gente conseguiu
mas vocês tenham em mente que isso é o
primeiro passo próximo ano vai ser o
mais difícil porque próximo ano a gente
vai ter que fazer o sistema funcionar
a gente vai ter que fazer com que as
pessoas saibam destinar corretamente os
seus resíduos dentro da escola ou no
entorno da escola e uma escola
como todo lugar de convivência social é
um espaço que tem pessoas de diversas
educações então vocês imaginam fazer com
que as crianças e os jovens dentro de
uma escola consigam é depositar
corretamente resíduos e chego em casa é
uma outra ideia outro formato
então é de fato muito difícil e esse ano
a gente está fazendo isso e está difícil
está cheio de problemáticas e obstáculos
mas o mais bacana o mais importante a
gente perceber o quanto eles estão
engajados em fazer acontecer a cada
obstáculo que chega cada problemática
que chega eles passam por cima eles
criam uma solução e aí está o grande
brilho do projeto e diz a intenção da
inovação social dentro das escolas
então tentei de todas essas experiências
e comecei a pensar eu acho que consegui
achar a minha missão é a minha missão de
fato é fazer com que todos enxergam em o
poder de transformação que a gente está
desperdiçando dentro da escola
esses meninos têm um poder muito grande
pra gente está torcendo eles pra gente
dizendo que
é o caminho está dizendo que vai vai
ficar com medo porque o erro nem sempre
é bom que a gente precisa começar a
pensar nessa potência que a gente tem
que aproveitar essa potência para o
impacto social
eu quero mostrar também é que mais do
que se atualizar as escolas precisam ser
lançadoras de tendências e estou falando
aqui de tendências sociais
as escolas precisam ser espaços de
vanguarda precisam ser centros do novo
da novidade
a gente precisa aproveitar isso que vem
genuinamente das nossas crianças e
jovens e provavelmente vocês devem
conhecer grupos de estudantes de uma
escola específico duas ou três que têm
projetos bacanas na área social e tem
projetos interessantes mas porque a
gente conhece um dois três grupos
por que a gente não conhece ou não deixa
acontecer isso em todas as escolas
não é porque a gente não está lá isso
porque se porque a gente não faz isso
acontecer dia a dia ano dentro das
escolas
a gente precisa incentivar isso dentro
das nossas escolas
você imagine as escolas trabalham
inovação social todos os dias assim como
trabalham o português e matemática e
outras disciplinas
você imagina o que é as crianças abusam
dos seus olhares críticos e olhando para
o entorno da escola e olhando para as
problemáticas que existem dentro da
sociedade e de busca dessas soluções é
muito é muito forte e por isso que eu
digo é eu defendo muito que a gente
precisa lutar para transformar as
escolas em laboratórios de inovação
social
a gente precisa fazer isso acontecer
dentro das nossas escolas sejam públicas
ou privadas
muitos de vocês devem ser pais e mães
todos aqui cidadãos na professores
educadores gestores da escola está nas
nossas mãos
se a gente quiser transformar seja
quiser remodela educação para que a
escola passa a ser um espaço de
vanguarda a gente consegue
eu tenho conseguido algumas escolas eu
tenho dado uma participação legal em
relação a isso junto com os alunos
junto com os educadores junto com os
professores e se envolvem com a gente
nos projetos
então a gente pode eu queria que vocês
hoje
e é sair daqui com essa vontade
estimulados a fazer isso quando comecei
a minha fala que eu falei pra vocês que
estava muito feliz em estar participando
cadex dentro de uma escola
e eu digo isso porque esse momento aqui
eu tô aqui em cima falando para vocês
vocês me escutando ele comprova que as
escolas estão se mexendo
elas estão fazendo por onde a gente
trazer novas idéias vocês estão aí
alimenta se alimentando de idéias desde
o começo da tarde de hoje precisa fazer
isso sair do papel
na idéia do dá essa idéia de hoje do
pedex é fazer com que a gente saia daqui
inquieto né e eu espero a do fundo do
meu coração eu tenho conseguido fazer
com que vocês pensem ou cogitem pelo
menos e todas as escolas precisam trazer
inovação social para dentro delas
se eu tiver conseguido isso eu acredito
que consegui fazer a minha micro
revolução do dia e fico muito grato por
isso
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]